بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين والصلاه والسلام على رسوله
الكريم وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين واشهد ان
لا اله الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده
ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين
اما بعد
الصالحين
النووي رحمه الله تعالى
سعد بن ابي وقاس رضي الله عنه
سعدن ابي وقاس
حجه الوداع حجه الوداعه
سعد بن ابي وقاس
مكه مدينه
حجه الوداع
‏was
صلى الله عليه وسلم
سعد
veryalthy man was ulty among comp
and was always the case
الله سبحانه وتالى
[Silence]
she's
‏un out
a male could a bo couldale
a son and so this was
one of the reasons that he asked the
propet
what i do with thisth and so asked him
you see the st
[Silence]
صل الله عليه وسلم
سعد
صلى الله عليه وسلم
فثلث قال الثلث والثلث كبير او كثير
andased
we understand that
ابو بكر رضي الله عنه خلافه
الله سبحانه وتعالى
غنيمه انفال
صلى الله عليه وسلم
سعد الثلث والثلث كثير او كبير هذا
شك من الراوي كثير
او كبير هذا شك من ايش؟ شك من الراوي يعني
راوي الحديث
اي شك في الروايه هل هي كثير او كبير؟ طب
ايش الفرق؟ ليس بينهما فرق يذكر اي من
ناحيه ال اللغه وانما هذا من باب ورع
الرواه انهم يتورعون ان يقولوا على رسول
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم ما لم يستيقنوا
انه قال صلى الله عليه وسلم وهذا يدل ليس
على ضعف
حفظ الراوي بل يدل على اتقان الراوي لانه
ما شك في شيء الا كثير او كبير وفي
الكتابه
كلمه كبير وكثير مكتوبه نفس الكتابه نفس
الخط اذا ما في فرق يقول انك ان تذر ورثتك
هذا كلام الرسول صل صلى الله عليه وسلم
يقول لسعد وبالتالي يقول لجميع المسلمين
من بعده انك ان تذر ورثتك اغنياء
خير من ان تذرهم عاله يعني فقراء يتكففون
الناس يتكففون
الناس ماخوذ من الكف يعني فاتحين اكفهم
الى الناس يطلبون منهم
ذا بروفيت صلى الله عليه
سعد
for them behindalthy
is better than you behind po asking
other people to
have mercy on them and give
وانك لن تنفق نفقه تبتغي بها وجه الله الا
اجرت عليها حتى ما تجعل في في امراتك
في امراتك
في الاولى ظرفيه
وفي الثانيه بمعنى
الفم
في من الاسماء الخمسه في
في امراتك يعني في فم امراتك
صلى الله عليه
‏anything on your
and those you are
seeking
of doing socept
you for even the of food that you place
in your mouth ‏So
spending
money on your family members or you have
children and you have a wife and so you
support them. You are the bread winner
so to speak.
‏prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله سبحانه وتالى
[Silence]
نقطه هنا ما معنى في في امراتك هل معناه
هل هذا كنايه
عن ما تطعم امراتك يعني هذه كنايه عن
اللقمه تجعلها في في امراتك يعني ان الله
تعالى ياجرك على جميع ذلك حتى اللقمه تكون
في في امراتك او في في ابنائك هذا هو
المقصود ليس المقصود كما قال
بعض المعاصرين
يقول لك المق المقصود هنا
في في امراتك يعني الرومانسيه انت لما
تطعم مرتك
وفيها رومانسيه ربنا بياجرك هذا كلام سخيف
وبارد وبعيد كل البعد عن كلام الرسول صلى
الله عليه وسلم ينبغي علينا ان ننزه ديننا
وان ننزه نبينا صلى الله عليه وسلم عن مثل
هذه السخائف ليس معناه ان هذا لا يجوز او
هذا غلط لا لكن الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
ما جاء ليعلم البشريه الرومانسيه
جاء ليعلمهم عباده الله وحده دون ما سواه
هو اعظم من هذا
صلى الله عليه وسلم وهذا ياتي من
عدم الفهم للغه العرب اولا العجمه هي اللي
قتلت كثير من المعاصرين في كلامهم وفهمهم
لكلام الله وكلام رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم
ومن ناحيه اخرى تسرب فكر
و
ثقافه غير ثقافه المسلمين على المسلمين
لما تسربت هذه الافكار على على المسلمين
من قبل اعدائهم ومن قبل الاعاجم فانها
اثرت على فهمهم كتابهم يقول صلى الله عليه
وسلم قال فقلت يا رسول الله اخلف بعد
اصحابي هو الان مريض
وقد هاجر من مكه الى المدينه وكان من
المهاجرين والمهاجر
يحرم عليه ان يعود
الى
المكان الذي هاجر لله منه وهاجر من مكه
خلاص ما يرجع الى مكه حتى لو مكه صارت دار
اسلام لانه ترك هذا الشيء
فما كان ينبغي له ان يعود
فلذلك مرض في مكه وخشي على نفسه الموت
فالان
كانه يقول للنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم نويت
الهجره من مكه
وهاجرت منها والان اخلف بعد اصحابي اصحابي
هاجروا وهجرتهم تامه وانا هاجرت وعسى ان
تكون هجرتي ناقصه
غير تامه فقال النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
انك لن تخلف فتعمل عملا تبتغي به وجه الله
الا ازددت به درجه ورفعه
ولعلك
ان تخلف حتى ينتفع بك اقوام ويضر بك اخرون
يقول بعض الشراح وهذا
من النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم كانه يبشره
بالحياه الطويله
بعد هذه
بعد هذه الحادثه وقد عاش بعدها رضي الله
عنه اكثر من 40 سنه
وظن نفسه سيموت
ف رد الله عليه صحته وفتح عليه ابواب
الرزق وفتح عليه ابواب البنين
فتوفي سعد بن ابي وقاس رضي الله عنه عن 36
ولدا وابنه وبنتا 36 لما كانت هذه ما عنده
الا بنت واحده رزقه الله بعد هذه 40 سنه
و35 ولد وبنت كان عنده 18 ولد و1 بنت
وتقريبا 11 مراه تزوجها
رضي الله عنها وهؤلاء اجدادنا نحن لما
نسمع عنده 35 ولد انس بن مالك كان له اكثر
من 100
هذه سؤدد
هؤلاء اسياد كانوا احدهم مش هو مراته
وولده وولدين وبس ويموت عنهم وهذه خلفته
لا هذول اجدادنا هذول ابائنا اسلافنا
كانوا عزه اسياد الدنيا
عنده الواحد
11 مراه وعنده مش عارف كم من من البنين
وعنده الرقيق وعنده الاموال وعنده من عزه
الاسلام ورغما لانوف اعداء الله
نسال الله ان يرد علينا عزتنا اللهم امين
ان شاء الله
والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد
وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين والحمد لله رب
العالمين وجزاكم الله خيرا